guten abend das geschah eine menge
berichtenswertes heute das wohl
wichtigste in london eine juristische
tracht prügel für prime minister johnson
vom obersten gericht des landes den
lords und ladies des supreme court jeder
schlag von kühl distanzierte
sachlichkeit vorgetragen von lady
brender hale der präsidentin des
gerichts
es geht um die empfehlung des
premierministers an die queen das
parlament in der kritischen phase der
praxis entscheidung in einen
zwangsurlaub zu schicken
die stimme des rechts war glasklar
einmütig aller elf richter was da
geschah ist beispiellos in der
geschichte dieses ältesten aller
parlamente ein erstaunlicher tag der
bericht von yasin härle
schauen sie genau hin und dann reiben
sie sich kräftig die augen das was sich
hier vor vier wochen im house of lords
abspielte die aussetzung des parlaments
hat sozusagen gar nicht stattgefunden
großbritanniens oberster richter haben
heute entschieden dass der
premierminister gesetzeswidrig gehandelt
hat sehr real ist wie die richter die
macht balance im königreich nun wieder
zurecht gerückt haben bereits im jahr
1611 haben die gerichte festgestellt
dass der könig der damals die regierung
war kein vorrecht über das hat was das
recht des landes ihm erlaubt
großbritannien hat sich auf das besonnen
auf was es so lange so stolz ist seine
demokratie die große frage heute aber
war wie der mann der so hart in seine
schranken verwiesen wurde reagieren
würde
boris johnson wollte heute in new york
bei der uno und nahm die gelegenheit
wahr weiter den schulterschluss mit
donald trump zu suchen kleiner
pressekonferenz dann diese worte wir
respektieren die justiz und die gerichte
unseres landes aber ich bin absolut
nicht einverstanden mit ihrem urteil
dies musste jenen die den fall vor
gericht gebracht hatten geradezu die
sprache verschlagen wie der
geschäftsfrau china müller die sich
schon mehrfach für die rechte des
parlaments eingesetzt hat
dürfen herrn johnson nicht erlauben
herunter zu spielen was hier passiert
ist elf der höchsten richter dieses
landes haben einstimmig geurteilt dass
er die königin rechtswidrig beraten hat
und die tatsache dass er sich dafür
nicht entschuldigen will und sagt dass
er damit nicht einverstanden ist
erscheint mir fast genauso schockierend
wie unser sieg boris johnson so scheint
es hat sich verkalkuliert mit der
aussetzung des parlaments ist er wohl
einen schritt zu weit gegangen und im
resultat eine zersplitterte opposition
nun geeint und entschlossen gegen sich
zu haben und der vorsitzende der größten
aber zuletzt eher uneffektiven
oppositionspartei wird hat seine chance
boris johnson raus rufen sie und jeremic
corbijn setzt nach diese ungewählten
premierminister sollte nun zurücktreten
ein misstrauensantrag gegen johnson wäre
nun der logische schluss doch corbijn
zögert noch er will erst sicher gehen
dass der bretone abkommt nicht
stattfindet wie er sagt morgen sitzt das
parlament also wieder
es war ja eigentlich nie weg gewesen
doch niemand weiß welchen
ausserordentlichen schachzug der premier
und seine ratgeber als nächstes geplant
haben
die jahner vor gericht stand ja nicht
der brh exit vor gericht stand die
aufhebung des parlaments vor fünf wochen
jetzt kommt das parlament zurück was
heißt das für den wechsel für den praxis
heißt das dass er eine haarige
angelegenheit ist sehr viel haariger als
boris johnson das mal versprochen hat
und für boris johnson heißt es dass er
nicht mehr sehr viel spielraum hat
er hat heute zwar immer wieder unbeirrt
betont großbritannien werde am 31
oktober austreten
aber auch das wird sich wohl als unwahr
erweisen den ungeordneten dragset mit
dem johnson solange gedroht
den hat ihm das parlament ja schon per
gesetz verboten und den austritt mit die
einen dienen an dem er arbeitet bei dem
er aber nicht voran kommt der ist heute
noch einmal unwahrscheinlicher geworden
denn erstens hat ja seine
regierungspartei keine mehrheit mehr im
parlament
und zweitens wie sollte er jemals einen
den er aus brüssel mit nach hause bringt
durch dieses parlament dass er so gegen
sich aufgebracht hat durch besetzen
können das ist jetzt eine sehr englische
situation wir wissen was alles nicht
geht und jetzt kommt die schwierige
frage weil es schon so viele
überraschungen gab was ist denn jetzt
ein wahrscheinliches szenario das
passieren könnte
ein wahrscheinliches szenario
ok also ein wahrscheinliches szenario
ist dass der brechtsche termin
verschoben wird dass er nicht am 31
oktober stattfindet und dass es dann zu
neuwahlen kommt vermutlich im november
oder im dezember und dann wird es wieder
spannend denn wenn auch heute eine
knappe mehrheit der briten gesagt hat
boris johnson müsse nun zurücktreten
beginnt erstmal der wahlkampf stehen die
dinge wieder anders dann wird boris
johnson sich hinstellen und sich
wiederum verkaufen als der held des brh
exit als der kämpfer für die anliegen
des volkes das für den dreck cit
gestimmt hat als denjenigen der gegen
alle widerstände gegen parlament und
gegen die gesetze gestritten hat um den
dreck cit zu liefern und dann auch
deswegen weil jeremy kurbeln der
vorsitzende der labour partei sein
gegenspieler bei 80 prozent der
bevölkerung als inkompetent geht dann
hat paris johnston wieder ganz gute
chancen trotz oder vielleicht auch
gerade wegen des heutigen urteils morgen
ist johnson ja wieder in town wir werden
sie nun zur rückkehr des parlaments in
london ein kommentar von wulf schmiese
chef der journal redaktion die
gewaltenteilung funktioniert also doch
noch in dem land wo sie ihre wurzeln hat
und sie wird dringend gebraucht denn ein
lügner regiert großbritannien boris
johnson hat sein volk belogen mit der
praxis kampagne
er hat die queen getäuscht um sich das
parlament vom hals zu schaffen
er hat seine konservative partei
gesäubert damit ihm niemand
widersprechen
er will sein land im alleingang aus der
eu führen exekutive namens paris die
allein vollziehende gewalt aber so läuft
das nicht in einem rechtsstaat das hat
das oberste gericht also die judikative
heute der welt gezeigt die legislative
die gesetzgebende gewalt
die vor ihrem zwangsurlaub noch fix das
nötige gesetz gezimmert hatte darf nun
zurück auf die grünen bänke im parlament
vorbei ist der bridge bug damit noch
lange nicht völlig offen was daraus wird
aber wir sehen abermals wie populisten
sich verheddern
in einer funktionierenden demokratie
auch in italien ist ein großer redner
klein gemacht worden das parlament hatte
dem durch marschierenden innenministers
salvini gezeigt dass er bestenfalls auf
twitter ein könig ist klar die zeit der
johnson und salvinis wird nicht zu ende
sein
beide könnten schon bald wieder
mehrheiten bei neuwahlen bekommen auch
das ist demokratie aber dieses praxis
gezerre schreckt andere populisten ab
und stärkt so die eu in frankreich ist
der frack cit kein thema mehr
hollands rechte können mit dem nexus
nicht mehr punkten und den wechselt hält
man inzwischen selbst in der afg für
utopie zu recht in der eu sollen nur
rechtsstaaten sein
daher war das heute ein sehr
europäischer tag in
london/großbritannien keep calm and
carry on